what's the story about you entering a  singing competition we'll see first of  all I started out singing in contests so  me and my sister who still my assistance  in today as kids we will go and like  when all the talent shows and we will  split the money and he would get 10% so  not too long ago we have to try hand at  it again and we were and we were in  Florida and we went to like random  bowling alley and they so happen to have  like a karaoke contest and I was like oh  I'm sent into this contest and he's won  and it was so excited but like they  didn't know I was Jennifer husband it's  like you just won $75 I was like oh it's  everybody come back next week it'll be  even more money I was like I will be  back  you